breaking overnight we have reports of at
least 10 tornadoes in Oklahoma severe
storms hammered the middle part of the
country from Colorado to Arkansas but
the area around Oklahoma City had the
worst damage by far Roxanna siberius in
Noble Oklahoma that's south of Oklahoma
City Roxanna good morning good to see
you
good morning Gail this is the main drag
here in Noble Oklahoma the tornado
ripped the roof off this convenience
store tossed some debris onto the house
behind it and into the drive-through at
the Donut Palace the National Weather
Service says a team will be out here to
this morning to survey the damage
this video shows a tornado on the ground
last night in goldsby Oklahoma hitting
the town just south of Oklahoma City it
was one of at least 10 tornadoes to
strike the state Thursday
and in an area known as Tornado Alley
it's a sight to see these folks pulling
over to take a look it is still on the
ground to the West in the town of coal
this twister spun up debris as it moved
along a highway hey there's a bigger
debris cloud
once the storm passed Crews started
cleaning up down trees and debris the
powerful winds peeled back siding and
ripped the roofs off these homes and
businesses in the aftermath neighbors
were helping neighbors you can see
everyone out in the street wanting to
help and make sure that everybody is
okay and asking if they can do anything
for anyone
four other tornadoes hit three states
yesterday including this one in Kansas
and in Conway Arkansas drenching
downpours coupled with strong winds sent
a monstrous 600 year old oak tree
crashing into this home
the rain was so intense in East Texas
this college soccer field was inundated
and several roads in the area were
impassable
the severe storms aren't over the
Oklahoma City area could be hit with
large hail today and Kansas City and
Omaha are under the threat of tornadoes
Tony
all right Roxanna thank you very much